you have a stand-up special that you've
done which is a new turn for you I mean
so often I see you submerged in
characters and voices and you're so good
at it and then to sort of be yourself up
there uh talking is uh is quite I'm
imagine a different experience yeah it
was I've always sort of done stand up as
a
um sort of a side thing like I always
had like oh I always had a little bit of
15 20 minutes of material but it was
always
and I did a special years and years ago
but even that special was sort of half
characters and half stand up and um and
then I just burped and I tried to talk
through it and
um let's play that again can we hear
that back and there it is okay I'm gonna
go on YouTube and check that out later
okay so enhance it too yeah yeah really
you can get in there dig it out um so it
was it was like it was always felt like
a thing I did on the side and then it
was like and I realized part of that was
out of fear I think because it's
you know doing the even like going and
doing like 70s during your shows like oh
that feels like more versus me sort of
getting up there and telling some story
from from my life it was like oh this
feels like more fun and and different uh
so uh ultimately I I wanted to do it and
sort of be like I can I can uh I can be
be a real like stand-up comedian on
stage for an hour and and do this this
is a pretty low bar
I say it out loud I'm like I really just
wanted to be on stage for an hour as
myself and see if I could physically do
that
but I did I did a special where I ate 75
eggs for Netflix in 40 minutes and it's
uh coming out is it yeah Conan Hand Luke
yeah
anyway so I did that and then uh it was
great it took a long time we I started
before the pandemic and toured for a
while and then the pandemic uh happened
and if you guys haven't checked out you
guys should check out the uh
the pandemic
the pandemic is on tomorrow yeah yeah
well uh the covid variants are coming on
later in the week yes the original is on
tomorrow the original is very bitter
about the variants by the way really
like hey what the [ __ ] I was here I'm
the one that locked it all down and now
there's [ __ ] variants what did they
come up with covet is a New York Italian
yes yeah we all knew that oh I think
we're right we were all pretty clear
about that
um and uh and then so I it and then the
you know life sort of the the fun of
doing stand up and the tricky thing is
sort of allowing people in to being like
here here's who I am or here's the
narrative I want to tell you
um and so uh the lockdown happened and I
got married and had a child and and that
sort of began to affect me material and
and ultimately uh so I shot it like
almost two years after I thought it was
going to and uh now it's done feels good
about it that's right and
congratulations on a boy yes a masculine
child may he be a masculine child uh and
and a little over a year old right uh
yeah you're almost almost two which is a
little over which is it a little over a
year or almost two let's call it almost
two okay I don't think this child exists
you seem very vague on the facts he's
um I guess like I guess he's sort of
people ask how tall is he's like sort of
purple does that make sense and it's
clear you've had no child then you're
just trying to use this no it's got her
information
it's got hair and all the parts
yeah the TV in the middle of the stomach
no you didn't have a child yeah baby in
fact you got the gay one
maybe may he be a masculine
I would like to do a stand-up special
where I'm really opening up but
everything is a lie and later you know
what I mean but I'm talking about being
a grandfather for the first time and I'm
talking about it and I'm really opening
up and I'm talking about my divorce but
I'm not divorced I don't have
grandchildren there's nothing Well cats
are real emotional like I'd love a I'd
love the real like the one-man show
Conan one man yeah and then our lessons
are learned yeah and then the part where
people really get mad is when I start
talking about how I was in nam and
people were like okay [ __ ] you you were
not in Vietnam and I'm like no no I
visited it was like in 2006. it was a
good trip
five-star hotel yeah